dit passons
dans tout un monde
dans
bienvenue à la tour beaumont
latour beaumont c'est un domaine
familial certifiés haute valeur
environnementale
nous sommes vignerons indépendants avec
ma soeur cécile baiia s'est entouré
d'une équipe de 9 personnes pour
s'occuper des vignes la culture de la
vigne
du vin et de la commercialisation
la tour de beaux mots où nous sommes
c'est le donjon du 12e siècle faut
s'imaginer un château qui a été
construit à ce moment là aux 12e et au
17e ils ont tous des construits pour
faire les belles bâtisses autour qu'on
peut qu'on peut avoir et ils ont
conservé que le donjon est donc cette
tour est devenu l'emblème du domaine
depuis les années 1960 et je suis la
cinquième génération
à cultiver la vigne et et à faire le vin
sur le sur le domaine les cépages
principaux du domaine est également de
l'appellation près tout en blanc c'est
le sauvignon blanc est également le fier
gris qui est un cousin du sauvignon
blanc et qui donne des jolies petites
grappes roz avel maturité c'est les
toutes petites grappes pause et en
cépages rouges le cabernet franc et le
gamay ici vous êtes à la cave qui
explosait dans il faut donc c'est une
ancienne carrière de pierres
et ensuite
ça a été le lieu de stockage de nos de
nos bouteilles
m nos bouteilles à en élevage et aussi
nos cuvées traditions qui sont élevés en
fûts de chêne dans cette can grosse
partie de vente sur place au domaine ici
à beaumerie saint cyr et puis vous
pouvez aussi retrouver nos vins chez des
cavistes des restaurateurs des magasins
de producteurs sur sur poitiers sur
châtellerault et plus largement sur sur
le poitou on propose différentes
activités sur sur l'été évidemment les
dégustations
du domaine mais aussi l'activité
trottinette tout terrain électrique
c'est une balade d'une heure en
trottinette avec des des grosses roues
pour être bien stable dans les vignes et
ça permet d'expliquer
histoire notre vignoble de voir la
biodiversité qui est préservée sur tous
les îlots de vigne une petite heure de
balade dans les lignes les chemins de
beaumont st cyr qui on revient ici à la
boutique pour la partie dégustation à
l'issue de la balade
[Musique]
non